- Did some of the sitting justices
on the Supreme Court
lie about Roe v. Wade?
Many justices who are about
to overturn Roe and Casey
swore that precedent was settled
and that principles of stare decisis
require Roe v. Wade to remain in place.
If they were lying, is there a penalty?
Well, Senator Susan Collins
would certainly be upset.
She said, quote, "If
this leaked draft opinion
is the final decision and
this reporting is accurate,
it would be completely inconsistent
with what Justice Gorsuch
and Justice Kavanaugh said
in their hearings and in
our meetings in my office."
The thing is, Supreme Court
justices have life tenure.
Life tenure means life tenure,
and the only remedy is impeachment,
which basically has never
happened in modern history.